ils sont jugés indispensables pour
lutter contre le corps d'un virus les
tests de dépistage se multiplient en
france mais ils restent encore
insuffisantes les laboratoires
d'analysés médicales s'organise pour
faire face à un afflux de patients c'est
le cas à saint-amand-les-eaux fou dans
le département du nord
reportage sur place avec carolina
béhague et robin pu l depuis lundi les
véhicules se succèdent sur le parking du
complexe sportif de saint-amand-les-eaux
le laboratoire de biologie médicale y a
installé son drive pour effectuer les
tests de dépistage du coronavirus ouvert
seulement le matin une cinquantaine de
tests ont déjà été effectués une
procédure organisée avec l'aide de la
municipalité pour mieux répondre à la
demande des patients et du personnel de
santé
c'était vraiment une demande d'ailleurs
de nos confrères prescripteurs de nos
collègues infirmières de pouvoir
répondre à leur demande de voir profil
états ont on a pu dès qu'on a pu le
faire mais on a mis ça en place
et parce que je pense vraiment que ça
répondait à une une demande de leur part
sont le plan organisation pour les
passants se parlent beaucoup plus simple
de pouvoir se faire dépister sur leur
lieu de résidence à saint-amand que
devoir aller sur un site lillois ou
valenciennois ces tests ne peuvent
s'effectuer que sur prescription
médicale
ils sont réservés aux patients désigné
c'est à dire présentant les symptômes du
coït 19 plusieurs personnes à risque ont
pu ainsi se faire dépister
mais aussi des membres du personnel
hospitalier en première ligne face au
virus pouvoir être fixé sur son état de
santé est un soulagement pour certains
d'entre eux je sais que j'ai des
collègues qui sont allés aux urnes ans
qui n'ont pas été dépisté qu'ils ont été
entre guillemets diagnostic et covile
mais qui n'ont pas été dépistées pour
pour ça moi j'ai la chance mon médecin
entre guillemets m'a demandé le
dépistage mais sinon à l'hôpital nom
n'est pas dépister systématiquement
c'est vrai que j'ai les avantages d'être
personnellement je peux pas c'est est
donc c'est rassurant pour moi aussi je
veux dire c'est ça ou c'est pas ça et
puis en même temps c'est pour préserver
aussi mon entourage le laboratoire de
biologie médicale pourrait également
être opérationnel dans les prochains
jours afin d'assurer les tests
sérologiques une anticipation en vue de
répondre au mieux aux futures décisions
du gouvernement pour organiser la sortie
du confinement